j'ai probablement très peu vu autant de
morts en un seul endroit
si rapidement avec autant de violence on
n'est pas faite de bois
on y eut même d'ailleurs journaliste est
un humain vous entendez présentement à
des extraits de nouvelle série de
ballades ok maintenant disponible sur
l'application audio de radio canada
depuis vendredi si c'est tout chaud
comme balados et en syrie qui s'appelle
envoyé spécial qui nous plonge au coeur
du travail
nos envoyés spéciaux des correspondants
à l'étranger donc le travail sur le
terrain mais est également comment ça
les touche
humainement céline galipeau chef
d'antenne de quelle honte en était
correspondante à l'étranger avec nous ce
matin bonjour c'est les jours car les va
vous fait un témoignage ans dans cette
série de ballades aux vous à mener en
afghanistan en 2006 et une journée très
très marquante pour vous oui ça peut
être un peu surprenant parce que quand
on m'a demandé de donner un reportage
qui m'avait vraiment marqué qui avait
peut-être un peu changé ma carrière on
aurait pu penser je sais pas à la
tchétchénie où une zone de guerre où
peut-être ça aurait été plus
spectaculaire mais ce qui m'a beaucoup
touché dans ce reportage c'était la
situation des femmes en afghanistan des
jeunes femmes en afghanistan en
particulier parce qu'on s'est rendu à et
rate dans cette région tout proche de
l'iran où beaucoup de femmes décident de
s'immoler par le feu quand la violence
qu'elles subissent et trop grande parce
que souvent ce sont des jeunes femmes
dans des régions rurales qui sont
pauvres qui ont été données en mariage
ou vendus en mariage et qui se
retrouvent dans leur belle famille un
peu comme des domestiques donc elles
subissent une violence atroce la vie est
insoutenable
la vie est insoutenable et comme ce sont
elles qui sont responsables de la
cuisine en fête avant la crise et avec
du kérosène donc elle sait s'immole par
le feu avec deux du carrousel parallèle
celle s'asperge d'essence au fond et
elle craque une allumette et là elle se
brûle
celles qui survivent se retrouvent dans
cet hôpital dont on est allé cet hôpital
des grands brûlés à érables dans une
aide particulière où elles se retrouvent
et voilà sur les jeunes femmes qui sont
souvent brûlée sur 60 70 % leur corps
poster des douleurs atroces et vous avez
parlé à certaines d'entre elles oui on a
parlé à certaines d'entre elles au début
ça a été difficile parce que vous savez
d'abord juste pour avoir accès à ces
femmes là pour qu'on puisse tourner il
fallait faire sortir d'abord tous les
hommes donc les frères les maris et
s'est vu que les femmes en afghanistan
ne se promène jamais seul dans l'espace
public donc il a fallu sortir faire
sortir beaucoup les hommes pour pouvoir
rentrer tourné ces images parler à ces
femmes qui voulaient tout au début qui
était timide évidemment mais qui après
accepté de nous raconter et c'est des
histoires d'horreur en fait parce que
c'est des jeunes femmes qui sont mariés
à 12 13 14 ans qui sont battus par leur
conjoint violées par leur conjoint qui
sont aussi au service de leur belle
famille et qui n'ont pas d'autre choix
que de rester là parce qu'elles ne
peuvent pas retourner chez elle parce
qu'évidemment dans leur propre famille
se serait vu comme un déshonneur pour la
famille qu une fille qui est marié
reviennent dans sa famille donc tout ça
fait que pour elle c'est insoutenable
souvent comme comme violence et vous
vous rendez compte de la situation de
ces atrocités qui se déroule tout en
étant de chirée parce que comme tout le
monde je savais qu'il ya de la
discrimination envers les femmes y en
avait partout dans le monde je savais
qu'il y avait une situation très
difficile je le savais dans ma tête mais
là je pense que ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup
frappée par ce que parce que on se rend
compte qu'on est allés en afghanistan
ils les raisons qu'on me donnait
finalement pour légitimer ou pour
justifier cette intervention s'était
beaucoup pour
sauver les petites filles oui les
petites filles qui avaient pas l'école
louis la burqa tout ça était vrai mais
las de voir à quel point le poids des
traditions est tellement lourd dans ce
pays extrêmement conservateur que c'est
là que j'ai réalisé à quel point dans
toute une région du monde quand les
femmes vivaient vraiment c'était devenu
c'est un fléau quoi de naître femme en
fait elles naissent femme est là toute
leur vie va être un drame va être juste
violence etc
à quoi ils ont comme juste pas le droit
de vivre au fond et la balado nous
permet de voir comment vous en tant que
journaliste mais en tant que personne
vous avez vécu ces événements là mais
comment ces événements vous vous habite
encore aujourd'hui mais ça a changé un
peu ma mon regard journalistique passé à
partir de là j'ai essayé de documenter
beaucoup la violence faite aux femmes
dans diverses régions les petites filles
manquantes par exemple qu'on tue avant
la naissance que ce soit en chine que ce
soit en inde il ya 100 millions et plus
de petites filles manquantes sur la
terre parce qu'on les tue avant d'en
quête toutes sortes
c'est vrai qu'après cela j'ai essayé de
faire quand je pouvais des reportages
spécifiquement sur la situation des
femmes mais mon bal à dos et un balado
parmi d'autres parce que vraiment c'est
une série qui est fabuleuse pour ça
parce que il ya toutes sortes de grands
journalistes qui témoignent des
journalistes chez nous que ce soit marie
ève bédard jean françois bélanger
qu'avec sylvain desjardins qui racontent
comment ils ont ils ont fait un
reportage sur des migrants qui passait
de la turquie à la grèce tout ce que ça
suscite aussi chez les journalistes
parce qu' est-ce qu'on aide ces gens là
où est-ce qu'on est juste témoin de ce
qu'ils vivent les gens qui ceux qui s'en
vont peut-être vers une mort pour fanny
mort presque certaine quoi dans les
canots de sauvetage on rencontre de ces
allégations tout en sentant impuissants
en même temps alors des bottes des tic
et tout ça mais ce que je trouve de très
important dans cette série c'est que ça
permet aux gens de la compagnie j'en
avais c'est comme s'ils étaient sur le
terrain avec le journaliste ou les
journalistes et ils vivent un peu les la
vie en nous on ce qu'on voit ou ce qu'on
entend c'est un reportage de deux trois
minutes après qu'ils passent au bulletin
de nouvelles ou bien au butin radio mais
tout le cheminement tout ce que vivent
les correspondants sur le terrain donc
c'est ça que je trouve que c'est
vraiment fabuleux leçon c'est vraiment
comme si on était avec eux en fait c'est
ça ça permet vraiment tout autre
éclairage au public aux gens qui
regardent nos reportages les reportages
des correspondants l'étranger des
envoyés spéciaux également donc c'est en
ligue 1 c'est sur l'application audio de
radio canada depuis vendredi on peut les
écouter c'est un syrie présentement de
huit balles à dos mais j'ai bien
l'impression qu'il y en a oui on espère
qu'il va y avoir une suite s'est
réalisée de façon extraordinaire par
danielle martineau et il ya des
journalistes du new york times du figaro
des gens ne le savaient pas non pas
seulement nos journalistes à nous donc
c'est fascinant vraiment même pour
quelqu'un qui connaît bien le terrain
c'est on découvre des choses dans cette
ballade aux âges et j'ai trouvé ça
fabuleux
merci beaucoup c'est merci carole et
merci